5 25 on your Wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy well we may not like
the orange cones the road construction
projects that slow us down every day but
we should not ignore or disrespect the
men and women who put on those hard hats
in the brightly colored vests to get
that work done it's part of national
work Zone awareness week and the folks
at the Utah Department of Transportation
found a neat way to drive home the point
that every person on every work crew has
a family
he comes to all my baseball games
he makes me laugh with his funny jokes
he's the leader of my Scout group
she gives me hugs and kisses and keeps
me safe
because the things he does helps all of
us
our parents are at work
oh I'm pretty sure everybody at the
Nevada Department of Transportation
would say here here to that message and
we may be able to show you some
hard-working best-waring folks from the
Silver State coming soon to a screening
website near you buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone and
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com